I'm really sorry to insult you but your
iPhone is starting to look a little bit
small at least in comparison to these
this is the iPhone 6 with a 4.7 inch
display and this is the iPhone 6 plus
with a 5.5 inch display yes these have
got bigger screens but there's lots more
in them too including new cameras and
NFC chips to help you kill your wallet
but the 6 and the 6 plus have new retina
HD displays that display far more than
you've been able to see on your iPhone 5
or 5s like a bigger Android phone it's
great for seeing more of web pages and
apples added a special landscape mode
for the home screen with the 6 plus on
both phones you can move through web
pages and emails with swipes on the side
but I really prefer the smaller version
for my smaller hands the 5.5 inch
version looks like a small tablet both
the new phones have 8 megapixel cameras
with new sensors inside and they have a
new and faster
a8 processor but the biggest
game-changer in here might be the NFC
chip which is trying to kill my
humongous wallet called Apple pay you'll
be able to register your credit card or
bank account with Apple and you'll be
able to pay in stores by just tapping
the phone and holding down the touch ID
fingerprint sensor apples work with lots
of stores including Starbucks subway and
some others of course there are plenty
of security and privacy questions though
Apple says when you add a new credit
card we don't store the credit card
number and we don't give it to the
merger this list starts at 199 dollars
and the 6 plus starts at 299 dollars
both will be available for order this
coming Friday and on sale in stores the
following Friday stay tuned for our full
review